hey welcome to a new project camp update
it's early in the morning
sun is rising and uh today is gonna be a
very
special big day yeah so we basically
bought this big
piece of land and a prototyping a more
sustainable way of living
not sure how it's gonna go but let's see
and you might have seen on our other
channel that we converted two shipping
containers to drop here one has the
workspace and one the town center with
kitchen and shower and stuff
and in the previous update you could see
us trying to get the containers here
so first they've been dropped very
sketchy in portugal
but then we had to wait for the roads to
be clean
and the weather to be good so the
containers could actually be dropped
here and it's not too
muddy and soggy and there's enough space
and today
finally that moment came so today the
containers are arriving
ground is cleared and they're gonna be
dropped right there
we've been waiting for this for weeks
months
for this day to happen and so yeah
exciting day
so today is a big day
[Music]
it's happening so they're coming with
two trucks because the truck
from the guy can only lift up to five
tons and this container is 5.7 tons
so we ask his friend to help out
so one stupid thing i forgot
the key it's in my jacket which i left
at the friend's place in porto
so i cannot open it now so we have to
level it with this
tiny thing which i had here because all
our tools are in here so i can't
access it
so first the containers lifted up and
then it made a 180 degree turn so the
door was facing the right side
and then it just went down it had to go
back up and down a few times for
leveling
but that's kind of it the whole thing
took about 20 to 30 minutes
so first container sat down was actually
super smooth
and next is gonna be the kitchen
[Music]
so
okay okay so both containers arrived
kind of a big deal waited long for this
moment
so a lot of tension coming out and today
is also saturday which means the little
local shop
in town sells pasta in the weekend
so it seems like a perfect time for a
little celebration
so i just fell off my bike
i was filming and going downhill using
the front
brake front flap thing
oh yeah lesson learned
don't learn cycle and film
when you go downhill
time to celebrate though
[Applause]
oh
uh yeah so now it's time to open them up
always a bit scary after such a long
journey to see how everything is inside
warning though we also didn't really
pack it super nicely as then we put
everything on the floor
so it probably looks a bit messy but
let's see
[Music]
combination is my birthday
looking good so it looks like everything
is still
pretty good shower's still alive bulk
food is there
the blankets didn't even fall out during
the journey
here we have crates with a lot of stuff
from kitchen cutting boards
yeah whatever brushes here we have a
massive big table
from a bowling track we don't really
need it this big
we don't even have that many people
around here and we don't have an outside
space to put it like covered for the
ring
but we didn't want to throw it away or
sell it back home
so we just brought it for the future and
same for this tube was a potential
flagpole
a big ladder a tabletop you didn't want
to true
um but the ceramics are still
intact overall everything still looks
very good like really nothing
broken nothing messed up so time to
unpack
[Music]
so this table is being a bit tricky now
because we put it in with six people but
at the moment we don't have six people
to lift it up
but it's blocking all the entrances
it's it sounded very logical when we put
it in to have a big table
but now being here it's like hmm why why
would we want a big table like that
yeah let's see
uh
[Music]
yeah so finally we managed to get it out
now time to set up everything
but for some reason even though it's a
closed box everything got very dusty
so perhaps for some cleaning
[Music]
so the kitchen is now all set up i'll
show the results later
because first we're gonna go to the
workspace
so workspace same story a lot of stuff
on the floor
fresh plastic doom all the tools are off
the wall
and packed around here we added a plate
there
to make sure the crates don't flow out
and
yeah drill press is here on the floor
yeah also here's some unboxing to do
oh small challenge here i see the metal
late
have flipped over from the side
wow okay
not sure how we're gonna do that
and during the unpacking i noticed
something strange about the things we
put inside
it's only been in this container for
like six months but everything got super
rusty
this was not rust before at all
rust rust
rest
rest so all the stuff is now out
really cool to see the tools again but i
couldn't really take
everything because some stuff is too
heavy and i'm also worried the late
might fall
so i think we first have to try to get
that one straight
so the plan is to put a few straps
around it and make sure it doesn't fall
any further
and on top of that i also add a few
bigger ones so i can really tighten them
and hopefully this gives enough strength
to put it back into its place
yeah it doesn't really seem like it's
going back
[Music]
perhaps which i'm pushing still not
man really no movement whatsoever even
though everything is
super tightened
it's useless all right so next another
plan
so here we have the stick from the tool
i broke and a car jack
to maybe push it there i don't know
yeah that didn't work here
no okay another option and i found
uh another car jack and i thought i'll
put it underneath
and then lift it up so maybe you know
easy
i think you broke the jack cracked here
is a lead heavier than a car ah
so yeah that didn't work either all
right so last attempt with two people
pushing in a very harmonious way
nah so that didn't help man it's moment
like this that you really feel
weak as a human without the right tools
so next up our neighbor offered to help
us out with his tractor
he said he could just lift it up i mean
that sounds easy
so this yellow rope attached to his
tractor is connected to the bottom of
the lake so if he drives back
he would sort of pull the whole bottom
of the lathe out
and then straighten the whole thing out
to be honest i got a bit worried here as
you can see at this point only one strap
is connected
this prevents the whole blade from
falling and that one strap
is connected to this hook which just
snapped
i mean it's almost broken
people
okay so the machine is now flat
still not in the right place but the
tractor couldn't go in
uh yeah i went a bit rough i would say
also uh the drill is up which is nice
but in the process the drill head broke
kind of essential for a drill so i'm not
sure what to do and
i think some stuff might be bended here
so there's some damage on the wood but
that's kind of the easy one
yeah i think some damage control to do
but uh at least it's flat now so we can
move on so yeah as a last step we drove
around
the area to find a pellet truck to put
it into the right place
i just lift it up and drive it around
and this one's so smooth this should
have been plan a
next time
[Music]
all right so here we are container is
now set up again
i got a bit excited so i forgot to film
the setting up process
but it also went super quick actually
because everything has a place so we
just pop up
yeah you might have seen this container
being built in this other video from our
main channel
so i wouldn't show the entire container
you can look right there
but i want to show you a few things that
sort of happened during this uh
transport from the netherlands to here
so let me show you
so one of the key things is all our
tools are still here
everything was packed perfectly fine
super quick to put back up
because everything had a place so this
was same goes for
our little screw brackets all still here
another single screw fell out also all
the crates still in perfect condition so
also that
went super smooth so yeah during the
unloading or
trying to align the lathe we broke a
drill hat so we need to get a new one
support on patreon if you want to help
us out and when putting the lathe here
we also
cracked the wood here uh perfectly until
the drawer
so also here uh not really a big problem
and then our electricity box
right here uh there used to be a key
here
no idea where that went and a switch
here to turn it on and off
but no idea where those are i looked on
the floor and behind machines
i would say it should be in here how big
is it but
maybe i'll find it later but i guess
yeah we don't really have electricity
yet so
we'll figure it out later and many
things did get
rusty for some reason like over here for
this one it's not a problem
but also on our metal lathe which is a
bit more tricky because it's precision
tool
and our drill press so i guess uh yeah
we have to clean those up
but overall i would say the process went
pretty good
nothing really damaging happened and the
lay thing is kind of up to us we could
have tightened it better
the main downside was we just had to
wait for quite a long time
it took a while before the roads were
clean enough and that the roads were not
too wet from all the rain
and then we need to find a person to
level the lane
so that was all a bit uh tricky but
overall
it still went super smooth and the cool
thing now is that in the middle of this
land
with just some bushes and trees we now
have this super cool
tool box set up with all nice tools and
wrenches and
clamps available so that feels really
good feels a bit like being home again
into this thing so the workspace is now
all here with all the tools inside
but i got kind of hungry of all of this
but the cool thing is now we also have a
kitchen so we can cook a proper meal and
not improvising in the van
so let's have some dinner
so we're going to cook a dinner i'm just
going to chop some vegetables and film
and it's going to cook what are you
going to cook
any veggie that needs to go and
invention needs to go alright
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh dinner is almost ready it has been
really cool to use the kitchen
way more space way more instruments way
more spices
so far the only thing is that we still
need to solve the water issue
we have been using this jerry can which
we fill up in the village
and also we don't have energy so this
fridge
still holds our food but without a
refrigeration
so what we do we open it in the night
fresh air comes in
during the day we close it and we keep
the freshness inside
so now it's time to eat
so this kitchen isn't really made for
two people we have a lot of cutlery
and a lot of ceramics and a lot of bulk
food
and with bulk food i really mean both
food this
bucket is full of cacao powder you know
the thing that usually comes in these
small packages
here is 25 kilogram of it
for two people i mean that's a lot of
cacao
kind of dangerous so that was it for
this video
thanks for watching if you want to see
the next update so we're going to clean
up
more the area around here make sure to
subscribe
and if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
to see how you can help out hey thanks
for watching